hi everyone it's Jerry I have an
excellent game to share with you from
the 1962 interzonal Stockholm in Arizona
on the white end Bobby Fischer and he's
playing against Julio babolchin
Argentine champion in 1946 and 48 and an
international Master at the time of this
game
if you're a chess teacher and you're
looking for a good example game that
highlights Superior minor piece play
this is an excellent game to share with
your students
let's have a look
Sicilian Defense open Sicilian
and nidorf
H3 noted as the atoms attack
why it's prepared to play on the king
side
pay close attention to Fisher's
Pawn play
these guys right here
not only do they influence the D5 Square
once it becomes a whole
but they also
influence
several black minor pieces
okay
Knight C6 G4 Knight takes Knight Queen
takes Knight we need to make a decision
now after E5 after E5
we can note a couple weaknesses D5 D6
mainly D5
great Outpost Square
already white could think about a
strategy where we one day try and get it
so that a knight is on D5
and it cannot be challenged
that's going to take some work and we're
going to see that in action in this game
okay first of all where should the queen
go
she really shouldn't go to any of these
squares
because these guys are going to bother
her so she needs to take a step back and
wherever she takes a step back she's
going to be in one of the Bishops way
unless she wants to go back home but it
is better to go to D3 and be in this
guy's way
there are two doors open for this bishop
but there's only one door open for this
guy
so we should definitely stay out of this
guy's way
okay
from here Bishop to E7 this is already
considered a slight misstep
on Black's part
and I must admit Bishop E7 on the
surface seems like it's
completely consistent
when you play E5
this square is now opened up this guy
only has one square so why wouldn't you
want to throw that piece there straight
away
well the problem here is that black
experience black will now experience a
coordination issue
so by playing Bishop to E7
Fischer is now able to next give the
Knight a kick and when the Knight goes
to D7 this guy's stuck
it now means black must move the Knight
again before the bishop to before the
bishop could go to its main Square it's
it's a requirement basically that this
Bishop B on E6
to at least fight for that D5 square
that weakened D5 Square
so it is best in other words for black
to immediately put the bishop on E6 on
this move nine
and in that way when the Knight is
kicked it goes to D7
and black is cool The Bishop's already
on E6 The Rook is ready to go to C8
much more harmonious
okay
in this game it's Bishop to E7 G5 Knight
D7 Bishop E3
Knight C5 we're cool now with the queen
easy decision here we're not taking the
Knight
we're simply dropping back to D2
we're staying trained on G5 as well we
have additional support now
if you're wondering about this position
the possibility of capture
this isn't such a great continuation for
black because in the end this Falls this
Knight's ready to hop into here
okay
Knight C5 Queen D2
Bishop E6 only now
Queen side castles and in this game
black goes with King side castles and
that's considered
uh you know black is going in the wrong
direction really at this moment move 13.
the computer's suggestion is to drift
towards the queen side immediately with
Queen A5
and I want to highlight how you can be
continuing is why and how you shouldn't
be continuing here's how you shouldn't
continue I must admit my first my
knee-jerk reaction in preparing with
this game was to meet Queen A5 with King
to B1 to add some additional security
over A2
we got the Knight and the King now there
this would be a losing reply to Queen A5
because Knight takes E4 is gonna hurt
Knight takes E4 and then you would get
mated in two this is a winning position
for black so what should white play in
reply to Queen A5 it's a delicate move
but the best move
A3
typically you don't want to move Pawns
in front of your king in the opposite
sides Castle's positions
it's likely going to be in opposite
sides Castle's position but it says you
could get away with A3 why wouldn't you
want to do this well it is a hook now
for black to crack open the queen side
but white is apparently going to be okay
after the move F3 and nearby we're ready
to dive into D5
and we're going to have some Queen
exchange and white is very comfortable
in that simplified ending so
no Queen A5 in this game instead it is
kingside castles
F3
this guy is now free to dive into D5 now
that this is secure
from here Rook C8 King B1 Fisher set of
this move King B1
one never knows when lightning will
strike what do you mean by that
prophylactic idea we're getting out of
any possible tricks along the C file our
C Pawn is not pinned we don't have a
rook opposite our King
we're being extra cautious with King to
B1 this is a common follow-up after
Queen side castles at some stage
all right from here Knight to D7
some regrouping uh it's saying you
should go for F6 in the computer's eyes
try and do something against the
unprotected F Pawn play along the f file
not an easy move to make
okay in this game it's Knight D7
H4 so I was saying about these Pawns
in my intro pay close attention to the
king Side Pawn play
this structure right here
well once G5 was in that immediately
bothered
the Knight on F6 this guy here has been
kicked around
but also notice what it is doing to the
dark Square Bishop
it's completely restricted
additionally H4
has an influence on the light squares
in that it is preparing
to next play Bishop H3
this is a desirable
minor piece exchange for y
we're going with the simple strategy
exchange the bad Bishop for the good
Bishop
that's the plan
and black immediately goes for this
exchange and we could see nearby this
night is going to land here and stay
here in the game's basically over by
move 20.
what other option does black have
in this position because it seems
a lot more clear to me in this position
after Bishop takes Bishop Rook takes
Bishop the knights here and it's going
to be an amazing piece
but what if black
sits instead of initiating the capture
how might play follow
in a position where black goes with
let's say queen
C7 how could you continue
here's an important line to be familiar
with
in these situations where this guy stays
on E6 and says you know what you take me
I'm prepared to take on double pawns you
don't have D5 and thank you for the file
how can you follow up after let's say
queen C7 instead of this move in the
game
you could continue to push on the king
side with H5
and we're looking forward to playing G6
which does what undermines the support
of the bishop on E6
if we take this out a bit further
suppose the Knight is given a shove the
Knight gets to go into D5 and we would
be okay
recapturing with a piece on D5 and
giving this Pawn up with check notice
because the king because that earlier
move
was played on move 15 King B1 this is
not mate
as Fisher mentioned one never knows when
lightning will strike this is a
completely winning position for white
down a pawn but what's Happening Here
What's Happening Here
nearby there's going to be G6 and forget
about it your light squares are
completely crushed
also this could be a move in some cases
Landing a skewer if the queen falls back
in this position this is
destroyed the light squares
uh
completely weakened in Black's Camp the
attack continues the pawn that white is
down is not you don't even feel like
you're down a pawn in this position is
white
this is how you could continue
if this tension remains
in this game
Bishop takes Bishop
Rook takes Bishop
Knight B6 and here we go where two moves
out Bishop takes Knight Queen takes
Knight Knight Knight D5
Fischer on this move 20 set of this
position
white has a strategically one game
his Knight cannot be dislodged
end quote
it's as simple as that
the Knight is way too good this is a
dream position Superior night versus bad
Bishop
Queen d8 what is this Knight not doing
look at all the different squares it
could maybe make use of and I do mean
this F6 Square as well
there could maybe be some lines where it
dives into F6 takes we get some open G
file
an octopus Knight
how could we make it even more effective
in this position
Fisher's next move highlights this
F4 what are we looking to do
gain access to the F4 Square maybe the
queen maybe the Knight want to make use
of that square additionally this is such
a this is such a cool move what is what
is the F Pawn doing watching over E4 and
G4 for what we don't need that
control over these squares so let's move
forward let's give black something more
to think about maybe it gets to F5 if
you're not capturing and then you have
to worry about F6 maybe G6
all these different Pawn breaks are
probably going to be benefiting White
additionally this rank is now opened up
for The Rook it was only there to
recapture the bishop but now all of a
sudden it becomes an amazing piece
maybe Target the a pawn get to the C
file it eventually does pivot on those
two squares
F4 is excellent follow-up
the black takes Queen takes
Queen D7
Queen F5 so the game is essentially over
by move 20 and we kind of have a case
where black is just on the hook right
now and flapping about for the next 17
moves up until move 37 this goes
Queen takes Queen in this position would
be met with Knight takes Bishop check
and then you recapture
he'd win a piece so black goes to d8
Rook A3 Queen A7 Rook C3 we're looking
to get to the seventh rank
Queen backs off
we void the queen exchange we're looking
to attack still
this is nearby winning the bishop this
is no good
because we would have a fork
will actually first exchanging Rooks
would follow Queen takes
that would be game over
Rook takes Rook only now Knight to B6
okay in this game it is Queen E6 Rook C8
Rook E8 and guess what that night gets
to run in Reverse make use of that F4
Square
that's one that's the big square that
was given up with uh black no longer
having a Pawn on E5 and now look at how
sad a position this is for black where
does the queen go she could only go to
E5
and after Rook D5
the queen has to go back
um
yeah not a whole lot of activity here
for black only working on these two
ranks
these eight squares
with all the pieces and we have two
invasive Rooks a knight Queen
very aggressively placed and look at
this guy over here cools a cucumber and
even cooler after A3 what a difficult
move this must have been
for black to see I mean you just put
your queen in the corner and then white
just kind of flicks in this A3 move and
says all right
I'm just gonna make sure I have
this A2 Square for my king in the event
of a back rank check
you could take the time out for this
prophylactic move just like earlier
White made the step with the King to be
one
nice and cozy no rush
what is black play H6 needs some
breathing space for the queen
gets that there's some activity along
the H file now but
the attack is continuing from here H5
if G5 is in get ready because this
Knight's gonna maneuver to get to this
F5 square and be even more effective
okay in this game
and Bishop G5
H takes G
F takes G what's the story if black
instead of taking here takes the Knight
white could continue with this sequence
exchanging and Landing a check and
taking the bishop with the Rook
not the queen
we would want to keep the Queens on
since we have the safer King
the attack continues White's also up a
pawn
okay in this game it is Pawn takes and
what's the story now
white is in a pin this is hit three
times Fischer has seen
his next move
and that is Queen B3 out of the pin and
Now setting up
a discover check any Rook move
is going to be discover check so
black allows that
in the game it's Rook takes Knight
what would happen if the bishop takes
the Knight
this Rook would now have access to H5
Rook H5 discover check and the queen
will be lost
so in this game it's Rook takes Knight
rookie 5 check
Ing f8 and only one more move Rook takes
Rook
black resigns here
if the game continued you have to take
the Rook
lights able to slip into E6 with check
what are your options Bishop block we
take for mate
king d8 queen C8 is mate and king f8
queen C8
again would be leading to me
move 37 as far as this one goes
black resigns a nice simple example
highlighting Superior minor piece play
anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below I hope you enjoyed it
maybe took a thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye
thank you